uh hello welcome everybody i am joined
today
by a wonderful group of people we're
going to talk about how we feel about
the state of video games so far this
year and all the conferences now that
they are largely done um if you don't
recognize any of these beautiful faces
next to me oh i did it right
is jake from gamer ranks below me is
ralph who you might know as skill up and
then we've got young yay over the side
here with that beautiful background i
feel like i you guys outclassed me every
step of the way in this situation
i'm just got a green screen
it's not great
um so i wanted to ask you guys a
question and we'll just start i guess
jake you can answer first if you want um
how did you feel about this year's
conferences obviously it's another weird
year for publishers to figure out how to
approach having their conferences and
it's almost difficult in some cases i
think to even give a certain amount of
news when stuff has been slowed down due
to the pandemic so how did you feel
coming out of this year's e3 and and
gamescom i felt really overwhelmed but
also like i felt like it was like okay
it's my job to help like disseminate
this info and cut through and you know
inform people but there was
a lot towards the back end i feel like
gamescom was a lot more overwhelming in
terms of games maybe it's more indie
games that excited me but
i feel like it was way more going on for
gamescom and then like it was like last
month we had ea play which we were gonna
meet up and talk about and that didn't
work out right but there wasn't really
too much to talk about anyway right and
then e3 was
all over the place
yeah that's fair ralph how about you
um
yeah i mean i feel like this year
obviously it almost feels like the games
industry is not taking a year off but
it's just kind of like
doing its thing to get through as best
it can you know yeah because obviously
coverts knocked everyone on their ass
and so so many big releases have been
delayed and so i really liked what we
saw this year because it's like as in at
these shows because it's like cool
there's a lot to look forward to in the
future right now not so much but sit
tight and there's lots of cool stuff
coming do you know what i mean so i like
that and i think as well in general um
there's more space for indies to do well
at the moment because
aaa has really kind of like vacated the
field and i have really loved that about
this year and that's been reflective in
like releases but also in those shows as
well where i think a lot of indie devs a
lot of indie products got sort of
surfaced that otherwise wouldn't have
you know and i i always love that stuff
that's door is for sure my game of the
year so far which one and i feel like
death all right okay yeah sure i
absolutely love it and i feel like that
is a game that probably not as many
people on my twitter timeline would have
touched um if
there weren't kind of a lot though that
said i don't know if you guys have been
playing death loop
no not recently no
okay
i i'm playing it and it's very good
um that's obviously coming out next
month and then psychonauts 2 as well i
feel like the last two weeks i've been
like damn what the hell is all this
fantastic video gaming that's coming my
way it's been really good um but young
how did how did you feel about the state
of the conference my part as far as game
gamescom goes
um it felt very middle of the road you
know they had it kicked off strong with
you know saints row obviously everyone's
been waiting for it to come back and so
to see some trailer for it was really
neat
i know there's some you know
discourse surrounding its direction you
know a lot of people
don't enjoy aspects of the protagonists
and you know miss the more gangster
style of
um
protagonists that they went for with the
previous games i'm waiting and seeing
you know i feel like i need to see more
game play before i can really gauge uh i
saw how many dislikes that trailer has
yeah
yeah the fans um
there's like
these protagonists look like they all
drink a starbucks like it's just like
really
all these like hipster puns yeah yeah
but because i feel like saints row three
or maybe it's four that i'm thinking of
it is four is very like flashy and
colorful and
i it just seemed i wasn't expecting that
reaction at all like it's it's not like
it's gta never has been not yeah
yeah i don't know it's just mainly the
protagonists and the that hippie vibe
that they give off is like yeah and what
people are rallying against but it's i'm
in wait and see mode i feel like it
feels pitched very young you know and i
feel like the saints row audience is
getting older and so i feel like that
kind of art style which everyone's like
oh it looks like fortnite and it's like
well yeah i think it kind of does and i
think that as they're rebooting it
they're trying to target a younger
audience
um i mean i didn't love the tone when i
saw it i actually saw behind the scenes
gameplay as well and it looks fun don't
get me wrong like i like the look of it
there's all these other mechanics that
you're going to be able to engage with
like building your criminal empire and
real estate management and all that [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] yeah i like that as well
it looks good and certainly as i saw the
action unfolding i was like yeah this
looks crisp and fun and over the top but
good but yeah even i was like ah this
tone i don't know about this one um i
was definitely because i saw it before
it was revealed and i was like oh i
wonder how this is going to go like i
knew how it was going to go actually and
uh and sure enough yeah it'll it'll went
down that way so so i actually have not
watched the trailer i could um i've only
seen screenshots next to the comments
that i did find very funny i don't know
on the line a lot of people keep coming
back just like when at the end she says
stay away from my [ __ ] friends or
something like that where it sounds very
like
you know the power friendships
i'm struggling with is like i played all
of them like from day one and
two got pretty goofy and then three
obviously went insane
and maybe it was just the way i played
the game maybe it's because everybody
makes their own character and they have
like a different experience with it but
i always made the most idiot clown i
could
and i never felt like the game was like
overly gang or macho or feminine like it
was just kind of
this weird clown show and this just
looks like more
clown show
which is yeah okay for me
there's an aspect of
saints row i don't think it's
necessarily the best selling of
franchises and they're just trying to
mix things up a bit to yeah like try to
appeal to a bigger audience perhaps um
and just mixing things up a bit to just
rekindle the series a little bit i feel
like it i i don't know if you guys have
the sales stats for that but i from what
i've seen and heard it's not necessarily
i mean i don't feel like a lot of people
played get out of hell no if i'm correct
yeah
yeah it spins it's still deep silver
right yeah it is abortion is developing
what have they been up to
oh they did agents of mayhem which
that's the only thing that makes me kind
of worried about
yeah because i didn't like that i was i
wasn't a big fan of that
hmm
yeah i mean i can see what the
criticisms to do with this trailer uh
like i'm watching it on silent and i can
i can see it but yeah
but i feel like i feel the same way as
you young where i'm like
i'm always gonna wait and see yeah
exactly yeah um
they did have a
follow-up video where the devs mixed in
some some of their own commentary with a
bit of gameplay and they actually
explained yeah what the direction of
this game was i thought that was a much
better video
they should have led with that and maybe
it could have been a little people have
been a little more open-minded about it
but
um yeah yeah kicked off with uh that and
then it it ended with death stranding's
director's cut which you know i thought
there was gonna be that one more thing
and it was like it's a game that we
already you know we've already played
but the new content looks great not
gonna lie um it's a really interesting
one because
they've changed so much right so like
the things that i really liked about
destroying and things that i didn't like
which i feel like most people would
probably say um
and they change so much of that core
experience of
being your postman self walking along a
whole
struggle of walking along a very large
open world trying to deliver mail and it
seems like it's so much easier that i'm
like this this particular director's cut
as uh in comparison to ghost sushimo
feels like they've really changed the
game and i'm so curious to see what
kojima has to say about it because i
don't haven't seen any interviews unless
they've missed one um that i know that
originally he didn't like calling it a
director's cut and is it actually a
director's cut is this are these changes
that kojima wanted to make or is it like
well let's get rid of the stuff people
didn't like like how are these actually
being made if they're gonna head in this
direction
yeah i'm very curious for me i think it
depends on when those new elements are
introduced like there's the catapult
building that allows you to shoot your
package across the map in a safe way
there's a jet pack of some sort or a
hover package
for that dude
amazing when they show that i actually i
felt like a like a gamer dad for the
first time because i saw that and i was
like i don't want first-time players to
have that that's too easy i don't want
them to have that i had to trek a miner
you know what i went through
real gamer hours
yeah um so it'll it'll depend on when
that stuff's introduced if those things
feel like late game items or should be
placed in the late game just for
consistency of pacing and experience but
yeah uh
i'm excited for this we'll make the game
a lot more accessible i think a lot more
people like it maybe exactly if it has
those changes i'm just i'm so surprised
that it is that different rather than
just having like 20 hours of more
cutscenes right
right um now we are adding new missions
and stuff as well like more metal gear
looking stealth segments some vr
shooting range stuff
race carts for some reason which i'm
down for why i don't know but sure um
i don't know it's interesting i just i
want to shoot more dudes with piss
bullets so
always
yeah what a video game yeah god bless
kojima you know
yeah it was a really interesting uh
ending choice and i feel like um i was
surprised to not see more of elden ring
as well um though it seems now that some
people had behind closed doors does any
of you guys get to do that uh not me
it was no but today i did i went through
all the information and what's new tell
us uh so it's a it's a it's a big old
map uh you can actually have a map you
can access a map which is big yeah uh
for their games uh it's interesting twin
blades are confirmed that's like a it's
like a souls thing which is cool to have
back um they showed off like two
different builds like a melee build and
like a magic build they explained how
dungeons work in terms of the over world
and how certain dungeons will
essentially progress a story and other
ones are just more organic and you
discover them i i didn't really i
couldn't really tell the significance of
that and like from software's spin on it
like from the reporting it might be a
little early but it's just little things
like that and then they put out those
screenshots where i actually like it's
it's been a long time since i've seen
just straight screenshots and i like
stop and look at them for like a minute
and yeah those screenshots are
incredible yeah
um
it's always next level they're so good
like i want to make friends with all of
these things that can murder me
yeah that's great
i mean you you look at the like the
textures and whatever you and you might
think i mean sure it looks a little more
lashing than cringing or whatever but
like just the the art style and design
and the imagery that they evoke
that's what people care about and on
that front people are all in on this
from what i can see yeah consistent
style though compared to demon souls it
really does look like
outdated which is very surprising but i
feel like demon souls is still probably
the prettiest game that i think yeah
this generation demon souls was made
by blueprints specifically for ps5
whereas eldon running out things and
yeah been in development for so long so
it was probably going to be a lasting
release which is probably why have they
said if it is still coming out on both
or is it
what platforms it's really singing yeah
it is coming out on last gen consoles as
well as
very least taking advantage of the
backwards compatibility is but i know i
know it is coming out on lash and
consoles that makes sense yeah it's
funny i just looked up elden ring and
the headlines are the most video gaming
headlines of all time which you know i
worked in games media sure for nine
years i've done this okay elden ring
might be from software's breath of the
wild
is that a game rant is that a game
it is polygon
but somebody had to do it and i'm sure
multiple of them have
but like they're like it's an open world
breath of the wild like all right all
right it makes sense but i wonder you
know you mentioned it being a map that
you can actually access
that's that's such a game changer if
it's coherent like i almost don't trust
them to make a map that i can perfectly
navigate because i remember when i first
tried to play demon souls
way back when it came out and i had to
give up when i got to the nexus because
i was like i don't know where i'm
supposed to go i just had no concept of
what i was supposed to do so it wasn't
actually the combat that put me off it
was the traversal it was trying to
figure out where i had to go next
i don't trust that if they
give me a map that it will have
waypoints or did did anyone say anything
about there being
waypoints i think it was eurogamer they
said that the map is actually like in
the style of like it's like it was drawn
by someone in the universe so that
sounds to me like it's going to be a
goddamn mess
okay which is fine i feel a little bit
better about that
yeah very surprising but yeah it was
interesting that we didn't get more from
elden ring but yeah
i'm sure they've they've locked in that
game awards exclusive yeah got it they
went out they won that award they won
that games award best playstation game
for 2021 even though it's not out in
2021 yeah and it's not out yet full stop
it's still won an award so that's good
congratulations from yeah
i saw jeff tweet that that was
not anything to do with him that was a
gamescom specific decision okay so good
yeah i can't make sense of it though and
the way they did some of them was really
awkward it was a very weird choice yeah
because their choice award was best game
of 2001 not most anticipated you know
not best trailer or something it was
just like this is the best game
playstation game how do we know this
like where everyone has played it
and also ouch yeah what about all the
other video games damn that are coming
out this year
hell of a hell of an ouch but yeah that
was that was strange um i also i was
gonna tweet it and i decided against it
because i wasn't positive but i was so
sure they weren't gonna be ready to
announce the release date for halo it
was like the reason they didn't do it is
that they don't have it yet it's like
they're worried it's gonna push again
they don't know when it is and then i
got it the day after i was like i'm glad
i didn't
i want to talk about that
you can talk about it go ahead so does
that did that release date announcement
seem very like quiet i don't want like
tin foil hat but they kind of just like
yeah yeah it's coming like they didn't
announce it at a thing they didn't put
out a big thing
it just kind of like leaked the day
before and then it was just announced in
a blog post i think i don't know i
expected like a little more from halo
i don't know
how recently they finalized that release
date
um it feels like it's kind of recent but
i don't know
uh it's i mean it's so hard to say
especially when that is that far away i
guess it is almost september where did
this year go but yeah thinking about
that coming out in december i'm just
really surprised i expected with the
kind of development hell that it seems
like they've been in and and all of the
change over that we wouldn't have gotten
a release date for halo until it was
ready
yeah i don't think this is still a long
amount of time that's still a lot of
polish you're gonna put in there in that
amount of time like i'm i'm just really
surprised and i hope it does come out
but you know as we saw with cyberpunk
obviously
there if there's publisher pressure then
things are going to come out before
they're ready and i just wouldn't have
thought microsoft was the
team to do that yeah it's fantastic yeah
they're already signs that um you know
there's some features that are not gonna
make it at launch co-op being a big one
for a lot of people right um for a lot
of halo enthusiasts and fans who you
know i'm not playing the campaign until
this co-op oh man really touch it wow
that's huge oh [ __ ] you're one of those
nice spoilers in the timeline then good
luck with that
[ __ ] i hadn't even thought about that
i don't even considered it but i won't
do it i halo's always been a co-op game
for me my whole life it's always been
something that i've enjoyed with other
people so i'm like
yeah i'm gonna ruin that experience
that's cool when i could have a lan
experience yeah and that's why i think
it's valid when some people say maybe
this game should just be delayed
outright so at launch it has all those
things so everyone can play it together
even the people who would play this game
only with co-op
yeah so the multiplayer is free to play
yeah most places we have to pay for the
campaign yes yes well or game pass yeah
true yeah that is a good point
everybody's just going to do game pause
but i was like does that mean that
that the
sales are going to be really staggered
for it if i'm not going to buy it and a
bunch of other people aren't going to
buy the campaign
but
i mean i feel like i still feel like
most people who are planning on playing
halo will play it on day one yeah i
think you're an exception in this regard
a lot by choosing power are choosing to
sit so sit out i think people won't be
able to resist you know and they'll just
be like cool i can do this now and then
maybe come back later when you know when
the co-op is up but i'm gonna do it with
my mates again those harder difficulties
maybe um but maybe i could do that i
don't know i just i feel like i'll be
sad the whole time that i'm not playing
it without like totally great
it's really wild to see them cut a major
feature like that this close to launch
given that this game is already like a
year late if you know what i mean like
this game was meant to come out last
year yeah that's crazy it's
i i can't imagine what state that game
would have been in had it released last
year and what how that whole thing would
have gone down so yeah yeah i mean i was
really stunned to see them cut co-op
this late because i'm like okay you had
an extra year that's surely enough time
to be able to do everything and then now
it's not quite the 11th hour but you
know because it's like three months out
but it's not pretty late to be able to
say hey this major feature we're not
shipping that at launch it's kind of
like huh okay that's concerning so i i
genuinely wish the best for 343 like i
really do um but i'm still really
excited about the game
yeah me too like halo's hello you know
i'm everyone loves halo well most people
um but at the same time that was very
much like a oh that is very concerning
kind of thing yeah i mean when i when i
heard that news
there is a subreddit for halo like the
last of us one where they all just
really [ __ ] hate halo and then they
clip you out now and be like not
everybody loves halo actually right
that's there's always one there's always
somebody yeah there's an element of this
campaign is open world it's no longer
that linear experience you're using
right and that's i think where the
struggle is with implementing co-op it's
just probably a whole different
ballgame with just and probably more
complicated to implement co-op in
in a structure like this correct me if
i'm wrong um if anyone yeah i know i i
expect it to be sort of destiny-like in
in campaign yeah
yeah i'm forgetting you know i had a bcd
presentation with them a year ago that
i'm now forgetting some of the details
of and it was definitely
you know it still definitely seems like
they're very focused on delivering a
very strong story in the campaign so it
shouldn't be completely out of order
or that wouldn't make sense yeah but i i
don't know it
it is just interesting to think about
i'm curious to see the the play account
with them going free to play i think
that's awesome like i'm very excited
about it and obviously it's on multiple
platforms like i love halo and halo
infinite to me looks like og halo and it
always did even when people were making
fun of it i was still like hey it looks
like halo one yeah no i'll take it i
can't wait that just like tickles the
nostalgia button too well so i'm i'm
really looking forward to it and i was
happy with what we saw just yeah
surprised by the release date and i do
kind of think you're right jake that it
does feel like it kind of slid in there
a little bit it just kind of showed up
which is a strange way to do that when's
the mountain gonna come out like it's
all screwed up now like i don't
understand is it available yet you know
they're making alcoholic mountain dude
did you guys see that yeah really oh
yeah
i'm pre-ordering that for a halo launch
don't you worry we're going to do our
review drunk on mountain dew that's the
plan what kind of alcohol
i don't know
the kind that goes
with a bunch of juice
oh [ __ ] did anyone play the uh the
technical preview
i was in nicaragua so i wasn't allowed
in they were like your internet's not
going to work
yeah i only only booted it up but i
didn't spend my time with it no gotcha i
played like about two to two and a half
hours of it um it it feels like halo
which i'm very pleased by everything
feels right the there were a lot of
technical issues though performance
wasn't where it should be and stuff but
i'm gonna
just take that as it being a technical
preview and we'll wait for a more you
know recent build for for that but what
did they call it was it a beta technical
preview i think just technical preview
interesting
yeah yeah i mean it looks great the ai
seemed very impressive to me actually
surprisingly impressive they teabag you
so that's good that's that's a huge uh
that's what we wanted
absolutely step forward for the industry
yeah
[Music]
respect down medium no i love it though
um and yeah the ai did look really good
and it seems like a lot of the ai is
voiced from what i could tell yeah there
are a number of
voices for for the ai that you can like
choose whatever i believe what do they
say
yeah what do they say i mean they're tea
bagging what else what are they saying
my mum
i thought you meant that but yeah i
don't know much about the enemy ai
because i missed so much of the coverage
of it could you use the grappling hook
in the technical preview um
i never picked it up if it was available
so i wouldn't know
i saw some gifts i saw some gifts of
people like i think chris reagan i saw
in the chat earlier i think i saw some
footage of him using it maybe oh okay or
maybe he was just linking something else
he saw i don't know but um chris uh
chris can you help out instead of saying
this
please
halo advisor do i want first please
yeah number one halo invited yeah should
have just tweeted him directly
[Music]
one where it's like a shield that you
drop down and you know i don't know i
think that's always been in halo but
yeah like a bubble shield yeah something
like that it's like a half bubble or
something it looks awesome that's right
i did see that yeah that was a pickup
yeah yeah hook is a part of that you can
pick that up and deploy that that's your
gear okay so it's it's an item thing i
believe um
rather than you'll still be able to have
your the same weapon loadout i imagine
but yeah i'm interested to see how much
that changes the game i mean i love the
grappling hook in in doom and all the
jokes about like it's just doom eternal
i'm like i'm all right with it i don't
want it to feel too different to halo
again because yeah you're dying like rap
looks so good too they like change the
way it works from the first one and i'm
i'm pumped i can't believe that game's
coming out it's really going to come out
they're really doing it which one yeah
yeah
no dying light two oh down like two yeah
right oh damn what's happening yeah
once there is um
there is one and again i'm forgetting it
that sounds vaguely correct
december 7th steam page tried to make me
verify my age
everyone is born in january 1st in
steems database every time
every single person yeah it's uh i i
keep talking about that game and i'm
very interested in it because um of the
what i think they're starting to do is
the beginning of something that i think
a lot of video games going to do in the
long term and i know that ken levine is
working on
is the lego building block kind of
approach um in that
the world is going to change based on
what you do and i don't know how
extensively they're going to do it but
it seems like you know you side with
this faction in a kind of wasteland way
there'll be more water available and
then the city will change and have more
flowers around and that kind of thing um
where i think that i genuinely think
that's going to be the future of video
games that we are going to see things
that are very very specifically
procedural
um i've seen ken's game
and maybe three years ago and i i mean i
didn't sign anything but respectfully
i'm not talking about it uh but the way
that uh to speak around the the way it
functions and
ties into his gdc talk that's public
anyway is is very much about getting rid
of set pieces in video games getting rid
of your songbird moment from uh bioshock
and adding in things that feel more
impactful to the player individually
because it is an individual experience
something that not everyone will have
that we replay something and it will be
completely different that we can't all
have the same experiences and i'm really
excited about that because i do feel
like now
uh a lot of video games are
gameplay with films in between and i
very much felt that way about
psychonauts too which i love but it
stops you to have cutscenes so often and
to deliver little little movies all the
time i'm like why are we not allowing
the video game to be video game in our
storytelling when we have such a cool
medium that we could do so much cool
[ __ ] with instead of like having a stop
to watch something so i'm super excited
about dying light 2 seemingly touching
on that a little bit i don't know how
extensive it's gonna go but um there's
so much potential to find out there's so
much with how
you know like so many games do like the
rpg decisions and it's like it's in this
rpg your decision will affect this but
it's different when they apply it where
they're trying to rethink it where
so i love games like like frost punk and
and stuff like that those types of
strategy games where you make a bad
decision and it's like oh god and then
everything is screwed up but for like a
long term and the rest of your game your
whole
role so to speak is affected around that
so if they can kind of marry those two
things those two different styles that's
like yeah that's all i want
it's super exciting for me the the most
compelling stories that i love to share
with uh you know fellow gamers if you
will is
things that happen to me because of
systemic elements that kind of came
together in this
way that created an epic moment that was
unique for me
um games like metal gear solid five come
to mind where you know i would talk to
different people about how they tackle
their missions uh
a specific mission and that all have
different stories to share and uh some
of the crazy moments that they
experienced because the systems just
came together and created this dynamic
situation
that only you can have because you
triggered things a certain way you
walked a certain way you use a certain
uh loadout and whatever yeah and so the
closer we can get to that where the
systems tell the
a lot of the the moments and stories
that you experience i think
the better that's definitely where i
think we're headed i it's it's really
difficult because yeah the the
hardware requirements to run that and
also voice acting is very difficult
because you are
piecing together there are a few uh
software companies that do it now but
piecing together different lines of
dialogue based on what you've done in
real time which is very complicated to
make that sound natural so i think it's
that they have to record a ton of takes
and a ton of different options and then
it will still piece them together in
real time but yeah i don't know i'm very
passionate about the idea that
video games in the future will tell
video games as video games and not as
everything is still half-life like i
think every single first-person shooter
is still half-life uh in formula and uh
it's like ken even said that about
bioshock he was like it's just it's just
half-life free skin there's like it it
absolutely all is so we're headed in a
very exciting direction there and dying
light too like i'm just so curious about
the tech and what it's going to do while
also knowing that they've had some
development troubles and obviously
lost their lead writer and have
definitely been through
some
hurdles controversy where that's when
that's concerned but it's coming out i
love the first game and that completion
rate was so high like they're
you know most people don't finish any
video games that they play but i think
dying like the first one was like 60
percent completion rate and that's good
yeah like it was pretty it was a pretty
dense game
and it got hard towards the end too yeah
but people enjoyed it enough
um
so we've covered you know all the all
the big video games really uh but i'm
gonna i wanted to talk about a thing
that nobody ever brings up or ever says
because you're not allowed
i loved ea's conference
i thought that ea's e3 conference the
first ea play uh hosted by austin creed
i thought it was so well done and i
loved that i think specifically they
were showing trailers but then having
the devs actually speak through them in
a way that was like a series of mini
state of place
if they if they continue to do that and
not do
the ea conferences that are like 20
minutes of fifa and then a mobile game
that i don't care about of the last
decade i would be so happy to see that
and i was really surprised to not see
more people be
excited about that the formula the way
that they approached it did you guys
have any thoughts about how
ea's conferences went down oh it's been
a bit so
long ago i actually just had to google
it then to be like
we got that lost in random game we got
yeah uh fight at them oh no that's the
knockout city update fight at the movies
battlefield obviously battlefield and
the battlefield stuff looked dope too
yeah yeah it looks amazing dead space as
well so
yeah i don't i didn't really have any
kind of like specific reflections on the
ea stuff like it was nice that it was
short sharp to the point definitely
better than previous ea conferences
which were legendarily bad but i was
okay with that because it was great meme
fodder and it made for great montages
right so i'll be really very snarky i'll
be really sad if they maintain this high
standard
i want them to dip back down like
personally that's my hope it's fair yeah
yeah i mean how did you guys feel about
uh dead space dead space interesting
death dead space
ethic
like obviously they shut down visceral
yeah that team and then they bring dead
space back yeah how do you guys feel
about that
man you know i really hope that team i
mean i'm sure the team is very
passionate about this game and wanted to
succeed and i wanted to succeed so i i
wish them all the best uh that's
certainly a cloud hanging over them
um but it's just like all we saw is is
you know the the a glimpse of the
engineer and his like back or something
like a shot of that and creepy room yeah
creepy room uh this is gonna be from
what i understand a remake of the first
game
um yeah i i suspect it's like a resident
evil remake though yeah like the way
that they did too
yeah they were getting some stuff here
and there yeah
which i'm also completely okay with uh
because i love dead space but dead space
actually i think still holds up you can
still play the first dead space and it's
still because the sound design is so
good
it's
still just holds up so them remaking it
actually appeals to me i just hope that
they don't put micro transactions in it
um they already said they weren't i
think i think yeah
yeah good news because i mean i i don't
hate dead space 3
but uh
the weapons crafting system and and the
idea of you having to grind
was just not what i wanted in dead space
but i didn't actually hate it as an
action game i think i hated it more as a
horror game
i feel like there's sort of like two eas
operating at the moment almost where
you've got their sports business which
is trash you know what i mean like it's
just constant micro transactions and
re-releases and etc etc i do feel though
that in the last little while that they
have put a lot more effort into their
core gaming side of things you know like
you've had your jedi fallen orders and
you know mo like a motiva working on a
new star wars game and
squadrons was fantastic and i don't
think it had any there was no micro
transactions than that that either
people were actually calling for that to
be a live service because they're like
we want more updates to this and ea were
like no no live service they're like
what the [ __ ] this is your one thing
that you do you know
um
so i feel like credit where it's due you
know like they are on that side of their
business cleaning up shop a little bit
and i respect that you know what i mean
um and so it does
make it easier to interface with ea and
be like okay cool i'm going to check out
some of your stuff now whereas before
every part of their business was like
how do we cram the ultimate team into
our games like obviously i do
think ultimate team has genuinely
damaged the industry i genuinely think
it has like in a very poisonous way
because then every ea game has to live
up to ultimate team money and every
other publisher has to compete with
ultimate team money and even the way
that they got ultimate team in it was
like it was just this perfect recipe for
it to be accepted because i believe it
was originally like a dlc or a
standalone and then it became packaged
and people were just excited about it
like i read up on it because i was like
how were people not furious about
ultimate team the minute it existed and
it was just this timing and this really
specific release that it just like went
down and and now here we are and
everybody's trying to be ultimate team
yeah i actually did a video on this a
long time ago called the wilson loot box
it's really funny actually the history
of it right because back in the day you
were saying your own video
actually
yeah i'm not saying my video is funny
i'm saying that this story is funny
because um
um andrew wilson before he was ceo was
actually just a producer working you
know with the troops and he spotted this
product in one of uh ea's other soccer
games so not fifa because they used to
do all sorts of spin-off soccer games he
spotted this product called ultimate
team and he's like that's really good
we're gonna go with that right and so
when those other spin-off games died he
brought fifa he brought some ultimate
team into fifa and then started like
winding up the micro transactions on it
and that is how ultimate team was born
because it was literally stewarded by
andrew wilson
to where it is today and that is
obviously what you know jettisoned him
to his his leadership position yeah i
hate it on every level i
like i think it it sucks so bad and i
i really think has hurt a lot of other
teams because they're like we have to
compete with this golden standard of
this exploitative manipulative thing
um but it also like when you're a
producer working at ea that's really
smart man of course i mean they made all
the money it's it's it's fifa alone is
25 of ea's revenue at one game and like
you know 20 of that revenue is his
ultimate team not not the box sales are
like less important i reckon ea will
just phase out box sales very soon in
the like next few years because it's
just a barrier for them you know what i
mean and they can just keep pumping
micro transactions especially
considering now as well konami are going
to go free to play on their thing
there's also a new soccer game announced
at gamescom called like yeah
uf something or other and they're like
yeah yeah something like that you know
so this competition i guarantee you ea
will eventually have to go free to play
on their like premium releases for
sports they just have to they
i feel like i actually haven't bought an
ea game in ages but um i know origen had
like with anthem it was really confusing
to figure out what you were buying they
were like five different release dates
and days yeah
based on what subscription you had yeah
yeah
you got it
which is actually yeah on time axes and
everyone else everyone else is delayed
it works
so they're certainly heading in the
netflix direction yeah
it's just it just it sucks real bad but
i also you know there are things about
ea that uh sure like i think the ea
originals program is absolutely
fantastic that's what i was going to say
yeah totally yeah totally right
i'm very excited about lost in random
really supportive like
published it's they made it
yeah it's so good
that's like game of the year for me i
think probably yeah
um very very good yeah they let this
developer have the autonomy that they
wanted and they let them implement the
business model that they wanted which is
why you can buy one copy of the game and
play it with a friend at no no cost like
that's i mean come on that's incredible
they also retain the ip
uh and ea
doesn't profit uh ea only recoups costs
so marketing costs included
it's just nuts like the fact that that
operates that way and is that indie dev
friendly yeah i keep trying to be like
what's the catch
why are they doing it
i think part of this is good i think
part of this is brand building though
because again like you know obviously ea
has just been slammed for how they
conduct the core of their business for
so long
uh and that's where they make all their
money you know like
70 75 percent of their money is for
micro transactions in their sports games
and mobile right so this stuff is is
like nice innovative comments and look
obviously there's going to be people at
ea who are passionate about making like
you know games for core gamers and
whatever else but at the same time i
definitely feel like the executives are
looking at this stuff as the whole
almost like the pro bono gigs you know
like hey we're going to build some
goodwill here so we can spend it on the
ultimate team product and we can trot
that out when our next senate inquiry or
our next appearance for congress do you
know what i mean maybe yeah i i mean
look i'm sure he doesn't give a [ __ ]
what we think like they don't care if we
like them or not clearly like they don't
care but maybe they do
maybe they're coming around again this
is the first conference that they've had
this year that that felt like it was for
gamers and not for the stock market it
was not for shareholders and
okay i don't know i'm happy about this
direction that ea's in and again i know
you're not allowed to be happy with
anything the ea does what i'm saying i'm
just if you point out the bad stuff they
do gonna point out the good stuff they
do yeah absolutely ultimate team is the
devil so that's still really bad but the
other stuff is kind of good a bit yeah
it's really fantastic
and not to jump back to the dead space
thing but uh you know with them
bringing it back i know a lot of people
are like very tired of like the remakes
and
remasters and stuff like that but the
way i look at it is that maybe this will
lead to more dead space games because
there was a time where ea had hedged so
much into dead space as a brand as a
whole multimedia experience and yeah it
didn't really totally get there but i
kind of felt there was the potential so
maybe this is like round two and it
really clicks and then we have this
whole cool dead space horror gross
universe
i think it's also a motive that's uh
that's working on it right yeah correct
which
did
motive and visceral did exist at the
same point in time i think visceral shut
down maybe just off the
motor but i mean my thing with that is
like i do understand like it would be
really weird
if uh
they had done that with like fable
legends i guess fable is a really
similar thing um in that fable is coming
back from not from lionhead they shut
down lionhead you were working on fable
legends and and now it's playground and
that that's not that different overall
but
i always
think on the side of the dev all the
time because i know a lot of them and i
try to be compassionate i know video
games are hard to make that it's like
the team at ea motive didn't have
anything to do with that most people
just want to make a really good game
definitely not of course not it's not
there they're not like [ __ ] you visceral
no that's not how it went down
um and i think it looks cool but i also
yeah i'm not entirely sure how i feel
about it morally i'm like this really
sucks like this rule was so good at
doing what they did but
i'm also really excited about dead space
so i just know that when i'm gonna boot
it up that i feel a little bit weird
about it but i was just i was super
excited to see that announcement and
also skate unexpected skates happening
as well yeah yeah um yeah it's being all
right the good news
if somehow they botched that space
there's the other game that the creator
of death space is actually working on as
an indie uh something yeah callisto
protocol yeah i've heard about that yeah
it had a really cool trailer it was a
cinematic trailer but it said
uh it's it's like a dead space spiritual
successor it's straight up like spooky
gross space horror
and um
it's weirdly enough it must be some sort
of deal with money and tencent but it
technically takes place in the pub g
cinematic universe
it's in the future of the pub g world
and it seems like it has nothing to do
with it other than just it says it which
is wild but
with the teaser trailer thing young that
was so cool like that was really
promising just setting a tone like at
least at least that i can get a glimpse
of the tone and i like what i see
yeah it's very much in his uh wheelhouse
and uh you know i mean he made dead
space so i'm sure he can work wonders
with the more modern tech and visuals
and uh gameplay play and i'm really
surprised it does look cool
yeah yeah
does it have a release date
not uh doesn't know what it looks like i
don't even think it has a window
i think i saw 2022 on here somewhere but
maybe maybe it does
um
it's that i'm seeing the year that it's
set is 20 23 20. it's probably
there is a 2022
rough one oh great
so neat that's awesome i had no idea
this existed very cool at least there's
that
yeah i mean
survival horror specifically is my
favorite genre of video game i will play
absolutely all of them until i die and
i'm stoked about it so now we get both
and that's great
exactly um
yeah to to change tone um you know how
many state of places we have this year
we've only really had horizon zero dawn
is that right
let's see yeah horizon was it
indeed was there an indie showcase was
that like an indie thing that i didn't
think it may have been
there was one like we just don't
remember this year at all i googled a
plan a movie from 2009 comes up yeah
that always happens to me as well
russell crowe and ben affleck yeah
that's right
what is that american football right is
that the one
it is yeah i didn't know that was a
thing there you go well yeah we've had a
couple obviously but uh playstation's
not had like a a big conference um but
we've now had multiple from xbox so
general question how are you guys
feeling about the state of xbox in 2021
and how they're setting up for the next
couple of years
i think setting up is the proper term
like this feels like a completely
different ballgame from xbox one like
they've got some stuff coming up um
and once they get that ball rolling once
they uh i mean and already i mean
psychonauts 2 came out recently and that
was i mean that's an awesome game yeah
uh
it this generation it really feels like
they've got their stuff together and i
mean
the bethesda purchase obviously is
massive i mean starfield is going to be
an xbox exclusive
that's going to generate huge i think
sales for xbox and for game pass in
particular which is what i think
microsoft care is more about
this platform endeavor
so uh i'm i'm really optimistic about
xbox's future to be honest i feel like
they've been
kind of knocking out of the park at
least what they're setting up it's all
about just the execution now you know
totally
yeah main line and games oh go ahead
no you go please
i i was just gonna say uh main
headlining games like it's been it's
been a little bit of a slow burn but
they've also been very very
straightforward with what they're
building what they're doing
and
i at the very least like that i always
have something as like a talky person i
always have something to talk about with
what they're doing what they're building
what they're trying it's interesting
whether or not you agree with like the
game pass model or or this or buying
this and doing this like they're trying
things and it's interesting and i'm just
curious to see what happens as someone
who's just like no horse in any
particular race or stable or whatever
the metaphor is it's fun
yeah i mean i i cuz i remember like i
used to work at eb games back in the day
did you use the weight there as well
lana
i did yeah yeah right yeah yeah right me
too actually
yeah
or like gamestop as you guys call it
over there but um right you know i
always used to you know you know people
come in and they would say like should i
buy a playstation or an xbox right
and uh
you know those that's the question
although back then was the gamecube or
whatever it was right and i really i
always think about how old are you
older older so
like it's always like it's always that
question of like um you know what would
i say to a customer like that today and
in fact someone asked me recently a
friend of mine like what should i buy
and certainly last generation i would
have said there's no way in hell you
should buy an xbox man just buy a
playstation like that's it no question
at all um but now i feel like there are
really strong pros and cons for both
platforms you know um and if you if you
were just to say like site i'm saying i
haven't met you before what you should
buy what should you buy i would probably
say an xbox on balance because if you
can hook into game pass if you're a
casual gamer and you can hook into game
pass for ten dollars a month and get all
that stuff that's insane like that is
absolutely nuts and obviously
playstation has classics there's lots of
reasons i'm not saying
better you know what i mean i'm just
playing like a lot of good games on
playstation
i'm just saying that deal is so
compelling and so much that it's it's
it's a differentiator you know what i
mean and i think that that is that is
gonna i don't know i feel like
i think playstation needs to answer that
somehow because the playstation client
classics lineup isn't quite enough
um so you know look again this is gonna
get clipped and spread i i dread the
twitter stuff god the whole like console
war stuff just bums me out so much
obviously
it's so exhausting you just it's so much
it's just oh but anyway point is both
consoles are great and before i would
have said don't bother with an xbox but
now i'm like consider both options
because both are great and both have
great strengths and that's what we want
that's where we want to be like we want
both platforms to be strong and that
they're kind of like fighting away very
brave very incredibly brave brave thank
you very much thank you i appreciate
that yeah that question when i worked at
eb games was always whatever your
friends have because i was working there
during the 360 ps3 era where i felt like
both of them were strong for different
reasons so i was like if this is a
casual gamer you're probably mostly
going to play the big third-party games
that are on both of them
buy your son or your daughter whatever
their friends have so they can play
online but even that bridge now is is
kind of
there is there is a gap there now we can
actually play a cross-platform as well
yeah
i have everything and i will continue to
have everything so for me i feel like
i'm winning no matter what um
playstation
i i feel like clearly has the strong
single player extremely high quality
titles definitely you may call me a show
that's that's technically correct but i
also genuinely believe it they make
fantastic games um and but game pause's
gameplay i own it i still find the best
possible configuration you can have
right now is a playstation 5 a pc and a
switch after that you're covered man
it's like that's it you know what i mean
like you actually have to have an xbox
you just need to have a touch point you
just need to have a touch point with the
microsoft ecosystem with the xbox
ecosystem which again they don't care i
don't think sure they want to buy xboxes
xcloud you're going to be able to play
on your old xbox one you're going to be
able to play like next-gen xbox games
using x-clap that's nuts
so yeah um that config i think is the
the place to be and then i will purchase
the steam deck and just ascend yes
i don't want one and i i don't i don't
have interest in it because and i know
this is so specific and i was like when
i spoke about this far i was like a lot
of people are going to disagree with me
when i'm playing pc games on my
beautiful super ultrawide monitor and
i'm sitting where i'm sitting right now
i'm in heaven that is my ideal way to
play a video game is right here this
beautiful screen everything looks
incredible
i use the switch usually for indie games
that are often already on steam and
that's the thing that i use on the go i
don't feel like if i had a steam deck
that i would touch it i just don't feel
like i would use it i do think the fact
that it isn't tied to an os is awesome
it has so much functionality also for
emulators is very cool but for me i was
like i'm always just going to sit on my
pc or use my switch i just don't feel
like i need one this is good because
you're thinking like a practical human i
i just think like a stuffed goblin and i
just need the thing and it's going to
collect dust anyway but i'm going to lie
yeah yeah yeah
but i definitely really want to try it
yeah for me i've grown really fond of
this guy right here the steam controller
and yeah the fact that you've got this
like once you get used to the track pass
with the gyros like it's actually really
really accurate
and um having that i've never tried one
it it's interesting i i hated it for the
first hour and then i loved it i think
that's strange for a bit and i thought
it was really really great uh for the
games that
works
sieve oh really
yeah was that better than keyboard and
mouse i don't know
kind of you know lean back and you know
it's convenient yeah yeah and with the
steam deck it's like it's this return
for the steam controller and you've got
this almost like wii u gamepad kind of
configuration i don't know if anyone's
played splatoon on the wii u game pad
but i i liked
that like aiming with the analog sticks
and the gyros at the same time and now
you got the track pads as well and um
i don't know i think i love that control
scheme and to be able to play games like
that again uh on in this portable small
uh form factor
uh i don't know that appeals to me and
you know recently i went back to like
delaware to visit family and i didn't
have my chonky ass pc and i would have
loved something like steam deck to take
that with me and play the pc games that
i have here
um yeah i guess like i also have a
gaming laptop so what the [ __ ] am i
talking about anyway you know like when
i went to australia i was playing games
on a gaming that's how i played death's
door like yeah yeah yeah that's true
yeah
you know
i'm gonna buy it like who am i kidding
i'm just in my head i'm like i'm not
gonna use it that much you know i'm not
gonna use it that much but i probably
will i game on a laptop it feels like
there's a lot of setup involved uh where
i have to like open the thing plug in
the controller and like i don't know it
whereas with the steam deck i feel like
you can just kind of
boot it up immediately and just sit down
and get right
it just works
i honestly don't know until i get my
hands on it how much i'll end up playing
it and how well it's executed and how
well it performs and all those things
will matter but
i don't want to know it big fans of
playstation vita
yeah me too so i feel like you know i'm
i'm happy with there being more
handhelds there are plenty of issues
that i have with the switch despite
knowing that i
this is the weirdest thing about console
wars is how often i get called a
playstation show or an xbox show and i'm
out here with my pokemon tattoos and my
pokemon themed username
i'm like i [ __ ] love nintendo i don't
know why you guys don't call me out on
this all the time
yeah very weird that they aren't part of
the race but like you know there are
there are issues with that it's also
having another competitor considering
how well the switch has solved for
nintendo considering how incredibly well
their games have sold higher than they
even projected
actually adds a direct competitor to the
switch so hopefully that means that we
get better you know features on the
switch as well maybe they're online i
don't think it's a competitor to the
switch personally i mean i just it's not
but they might see it as one it's my
point that nintendo may be like yes they
may be like handheld i would be
surprised if nintendo even know steam as
a company exists
they are just so in their own like
universe that is fair they'd be like
what what is this you know what i mean
so i would i wouldn't bake on that
either yeah that is fair
i suspect that in part they see mobile
as a competitor in some ways but then
they're not like they are creating
mobile games as well you know they they
do very much live in their own world and
i do appreciate nintendo for being
innovative in a lot of ways yeah because
of that but yeah don't [ __ ] on my dreams
i'm just asking for a better switch
okay as long as then
keep coming out on switch like that's
the only place you'll be able to play
your marios and your zeldas and as long
as that remains the case and it will you
know nintendo's going to keep selling
yeah
first party games are so polished too
they're really so
i still really like them despite knowing
that they look pretty terrible um but
you know that's that's who i am no
nintendo show did you guys see that um
gamescom game that looks like the crazy
pokemon if it was like jacked up and
dude
yeah
that looks incredible i just my game
jesus christ that game was like the
breakout gamescom game out of nowhere
yeah amazing it looks so
[ __ ] fun
this is the open world
or something kind of young kid style
running around south korean games yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's from the
people behind black desert online
okay yeah like oh i didn't know that
yeah yeah yeah that's surprising
it's not an mmo technically it does it
does not look like a real game can i say
from the trailer does it look like it
just looks like if the real game
actually looks anything like that i'm
going to be really surprised okay but if
it's within like maybe 40 of what they
showed i'm still okay with that and i'm
still like yes give me this this looks
too fun you know the the live reaction
of me it's not an mmo right no it was at
first but they came out and clarified
and they're like it's not an mmo it's an
open world rpg thing i had a i had like
a big
transformation while watching the
trailer first i was like ew they're like
weird babies oh this is surreal wow this
is beautiful is the frame rate 10 frames
per second this is gorgeous look at that
combat i need to play this and then it
just kept going and going and it like
was like a 10-minute long trailer but
i'm like oh i can't stop thinking
yeah yeah
or dope five they wrote out how to say
it it's like joking oh do you think you
should find that
dog fight first four dark five coming
next year apparently it was originally
introduced as an mmo but then they
decided to move the game in a different
direction and now it's a creature
collecting open world action adventure
that sounds cool yeah very cool
yeah and super unexpected yeah yeah it
looked like really neat um but i guess
that's a good transition into the last
thing that i was going to ask you guys
about was you know what are we looking
forward to for the rest of 2021 other
than death loop which i think is
fantastic you really should play it um
what am i looking forward to
does it have to be horizon zero dawn
seemed like the big the big one for the
end of the year and obviously that's
been pushed um i still think that looks
awesome and i'm not a huge fan of
gorilla
looks very very cool sure um no it
doesn't have to be 20 21 you can give me
the the
future excited for
oh yeah there we go oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah great minds great minds uh shifu is
looking astounding and jeff keely during
gamescom came out and said like i tried
the game and the combat feels as good as
it looks like that's mainly concerned
about like it looks flashy but how does
it play and you know to hear that you
know positive remark gives me a lot of
hope but i mean it looks like
kung fu and john wick had a baby and
it the combat looks so smooth the
animations the the fluidity of
everything yeah it's and the style like
it just looks really stylish i'm not
expecting it to be very long just based
on what we've seen i would guess it's a
pretty 40 bucks too
is it interesting okay and isn't it also
platform exclusive it's only coming out
on oh is one of them playstation and i
think i think playstation
yeah okay okay
um
it does not come up on google quickly
i've got play shifu which is an ar-based
award-winning stem toys and educational
system i'm just trying to find
not that
it feels like
studio is slowly working up towards the
point where they can pitch john wick the
franchise and like get them to agree
like yeah you can have it and you can
make a john wick game like
absolver and nowadays the next one
they're going to announce it you know uh
it is a ps5 and pc title yes sorry is it
shifu or is it pronounced sifu
i think it's usually pronounced shifu
i watch it man a lot and they say sifu
but julie i might be wrong yeah
could be either either way yeah i do
think it looks awesome um very kung fu
like i've i've tweeted about this game a
bunch and i feel like i actually get
often kind of negative responses people
are like how is this any different to
arkham how is this any different to
any of this and the play absolver
if you want to give me more games and
have an arkham like combat system go
ahead my friends like at no point am i
going to be like we have too much of
this combat right
if they think it plays like them like
man that's ridiculous how is this not
like power stone like what the hell me
just punching people like come on now
these are that's
gotta say replaced uh whatever that
turns out to be oh yeah yeah i've
forgotten about that at the very least
it looks gorgeous um
but i i just still i i don't know what
it is yet it is my only problem that is
the one that was very cyberpunky yeah it
was the one that's not the last night
it's not the last night it looks like
the last night but it's not the last
night yeah yeah
graphics are somewhat reminiscent of
something like uh octopath traveler
which is like this
pixelated but also 3d kind of
blend yeah
it has that look and uh
it's
you know it does look really cool yeah
yeah it's almost got some um
forgetting the name of the studio some
like inside like vibes yeah for sure
yeah um
yeah it looks really cool yeah
and it's kind of and that was what skill
up said about how you know
it's the indie scene is kind of starting
to really rise to the forefront while we
wait for
these aaa games that are getting more
complicated the development times seem
to be getting longer as they have to
continue to you know uh kind of top
themselves and then
uh raise the bar and stuff like that uh
these indie games are really coming out
and getting us excited for
for things to play in the meanwhile you
know and true
uh yeah and some of these games are like
up there in terms of fun factor and
narrative and whatever you know i mean
12 minutes technically
not indie annapurna but i mean the voice
cost of that just coming out of an indie
game was really surprising i know people
have been really mixed on that game but
um that like is a great example of and i
just like i always want to tell
everybody to just go play out of wilds
just everybody just go play that this is
the greatest game ever made please
it's the ultimate video game okay let's
just say it right here right now go play
it and there's actually an expansion
coming out like you asked before like
what um
sorry yeah i played for like two hours
and uh yeah i bounced off hard it's it's
it's i get that because i think i pushed
through because i was streaming it at
the time and it's really disorienting at
first in every single oh yeah
like how do you control this [ __ ] what
the hell am i supposed to control you're
terrible not giving me any guidance what
do you want from me you know what i mean
but then after it starts to click it is
just like wow every video game should be
something like this it doesn't have to
be that game but it has to at least
incorporate really big chunks of it
because
i mean yeah you like you talked earlier
about storytelling and games how it
needs to be kind of like more
like sort of emergent and player led but
i think like discovery is what i'm
really interested in because we had this
really prescriptive
model of like discovery within the last
generation of open world games where
it's like go to this map marker hey that
box is is shimmering click on like you
know walk over to it
where's that like that sense of actual
discovery and actual exploration it's
just so rare and no other game and i
will definitely die on this hill no
other game ever made has better nailed
that sense of discovery than outer wilds
like that get dunked on all video games
yeah yeah totally yeah right you might
not like it but like i will definitely
just die no it's a fantastic game the
way it does that is incredible i didn't
quit because i i got bored of or
anything i just like i play those two
hours and i got super busy and then just
kind of forgot about it so i should go
back to it but those two hours i really
should yeah it's like
it's this time loop majora's mask style
kind of structure but with every loop
you learn something new about the
freaking universe that you're in and you
use that knowledge to go out and kind of
dig out more clues and unravel whatever
this mystery is building up to and i was
like super into it um from like the
first couple hours that i played i just
need to finish it
it's also probably not a game you can
easily pick up and then leave for a
while and go back to you probably do
need to play it all at once but it's
also not that long so you can play it
all at once but i remember i previewed
it at a pax i played it and i don't
think i even ended up writing anything
about it because the impressions that i
had in the 20 minutes was uh the
controls
spaceship how to land and i was like
no i'm good like what is this you just
talk to some aliens and then you fail to
fly a ship but yeah when you sink more
time into it it really is fantastic um i
love how this spawned of me asking what
you're excited about
literally out of wilds was my game of
the year for 2019 and 2020 and with the
expansion i get an excuse to make it my
game of the year for 2021 as well i'm
very
excited show up at it again that's right
look at him go wait pull it in
that's right uh jake how are you feeling
what are you most excited about uh yeah
it was probably sifu dying light too uh
i guess for
2021 death loop from the previews really
surprised me i wasn't into it uh but
then i watched like one of the developer
previews a couple months back and i was
like wow this is funnier than i thought
this is more immediately engaging than i
thought it's a little more involved than
i thought it's not just like be good at
dishonored powers there's like waves not
at all structurally yeah dishonest
powers are there yeah they are clearly
dishoned powers
um yeah it's the one thing that uh makes
it way way different to dishonored i
love dishonored i think dishonored and
dishonored too the level design of those
games like i can play them forever um is
that the ai is not very aggressive so i
multiple times in a level killed
everybody
because i could i was like i'm just kill
all of them
see what happens and see what
information i can find when everybody's
dead uh whereas dishonored i feel like i
am bad at because the stealth can be
extremely punishing so definitely almost
like i keep trying to describe based on
what i played
as a
puzzle fps just one very big puzzle
that is also a first person shooter
obviously you can play stealth if you
want to but uh it is it isn't dishonored
reskinned and it's a really hard game to
explain it's not hitman it's not a
roguelike you can keep all your weapons
you could play it as a roguelike and
lose them all when you die if you want
to
um but it basically feels like
in the five hours that i played there's
just this huge puzzle in front of me
where i have to kill these eight people
i have to find out where they are at
certain points in time uh because you
can jump between each of the four levels
there you have four time changes in a
day and basically you go into a level
and say i'm gonna spend my morning here
when i leave i'm gonna spend noon in
this one then i leave afternoon in this
one night time in this one that's how
the time works so when you're actually
in the levels the time doesn't progress
it progresses when you leave and choose
what you're going to do with the rest of
the day and so like i know where certain
people are at certain times of the day
and i know what they're doing and i'm
learning about their relationships and i
have to figure out how to kill eight of
them but it is absolutely not going to
be possible for me to visit all eight of
them at once there is no way that i'm
going to find them all
so it's like okay how do i get two of
them to die at the same time at the same
event if i do something in the morning
can i get one of them to go to a
different location at a certain point in
time so that i can
maybe have three of them in the same
room or something like that and i don't
know what the answer is and i feel like
that is super exciting to like know
that yeah to know the video game right
from
four hours in to be like this is the
task this is what i have to do it's not
kill 12 assassins in this order and the
story will unravel it's literally you
have to kill these eight people you have
to figure out how the [ __ ] to do it and
it's just one really big puzzle and i i
don't know
like right now i'm super excited and i
can't stop thinking about it and i want
to keep playing it really badly um and
that's great after five hours and
something and yeah it is funny it is
really stylish um i think i mentioned
but some of the writing like borders on
obnoxious i think some people won't like
it oh my webcam froze that's a nice face
thank you for that
oh god i appreciate it there we go
um
yeah some of the writing i think some
people won't like
but
it suits the tone of the game really
well and also helps to make it really
distinct from dishonored so i don't know
i'm super into it i really hope that the
puzzle is difficult to solve i don't
know if there are gonna be multiple
options i don't know if it's gonna get
frustrating as you fail to do it but i'm
not even at a point of failure yet i'm
still at a point of discovery so i love
it
did you play no one lives forever back
in the day
i didn't okay right okay cool because a
lot of people looking at that like oh
has that kind of vibe and i just
wondered if it actually came through
like in reality you know if it actually
does feel like that so because it had
that whole 60s kitsch spy thing going on
yeah it
it's it's super stylish i do really like
it also everyone's talking about
forgotten city on my timeline right now
and i really want to try that too
actually i reviewed that another
timeline it's nice i i mean yeah it's
it's this nice no it is like it's it's
it's got some um it's it's very pleasant
to play i would say you know because it
just kind of rolls it's australian
yeah yeah it's okay so the story of
forgotten second city is actually a
skyrim mod made by this guy and the
skyrim one blew up right yeah and and
then it won like an australian writers
guild award actually um for best
interactive experience and he's like you
know what i'm gonna make a game out of
this so we wrangled in like two other
people they made a core team of three
and two others helped out they worked
for five years on it i think uh this guy
just like killed himself working 80
hours a week to make it happen
and yeah it shipped and yeah it rev it's
reviewed spectacularly well i think on
steam it's like 97 positive or something
um so people really love it and i
reviewed it i liked it uh it's just got
a few things that kind of really hit my
enjoyment but um i certainly recommend
checking it out especially because
you've got an interest in like time loop
games like out of wilds or death loop um
then you know you should definitely
check this out because it's i think i'll
put it next on my list yeah very cool
is it a stainless or do you have a
stand-alone game no they spun off they
completely separated from skyrim and
they actually rebuilt the game in unreal
um it's nothing to do with skyrim they
own it it's theirs it's just its own
story
yeah it looks really cool it's called
the forgotten city and it's out on like
every platform so yeah that's awesome
yeah it's 86 on metacritic which is yep
not that high but no but like again the
steam ones again i was like looking at
the steam because i looked at it i was
like jesus christ that's insane um i'm
looking it up now actually but um i
really like his name nick pierce i
wonder if i need to reach out and be
like
how did this happen it won mod of the
year in 2015.
97 positive on staying with a thousand 1
600 reviews so that's insane like i look
at pretty much every user score for
every game major game that comes out
because i cover it in my like news show
each week i have not seen a user score
that high this year for any game uh so
that's really crazy yeah that's awesome
definitely next on my list of things to
play i'm feeling like i'm gonna just
spruik as well end walker by the way is
anyone else final fantasy fan in the
house anyone i've just started to get
into it here we go that's it glad to
hear i love to see it
love
it is a struggle to get through which is
what everyone's been saying but i hear
once you get through the essentially
50-hour tutorial
then you get to watch it all like 90
hours but yup yup absolutely
it's such a shame that um like final
fantasy is structured the way that it is
like it could not be as great as it is
with any other structure but the
structure is it's also its worst enemy
because it took me 360 hours to hit the
end game for that and if i skipped any
part of that then there's almost no
point because the the point of final
fantasy is that journey you know
um and but but shadow bringers was
extraordinary it was pretty much there
is that what caused this resurgence
because i feel like i didn't see many
people talk about it now everybody is
talking about it shadow bringers that
brought people back in buildings a lot
of things yeah shadow bringers was the
best expansion and so it attracted a lot
of people but then after that there was
like a bit of a lull and then obviously
wow hit all its turmoil even before all
the activision blizzard stuff people
were just really pissed off and then you
had asman gold the streamer who you know
is the largest wow streamer buy a
country mile and he jumped over and then
that pulled a lot of other content
creators as well caused this massive
ground swell and off it went you know so
um but even before then like it
definitely wasn't just asthma obviously
he gave it a good shot but before then
people just loved it it's incredible as
i said it's so impossible to recommend
though because of the fact that it is
like you know
100 plus hours to get to the point where
you get to the
end game experience and a lot of people
play mmos to get to that end game you
know so uh yeah i won't do it because i
mmo's ruined my life yeah i just don't
have time for it anymore so i won't
touch it but i have watched a few
streams of it and it does look really
good and i also can't think of another
mmo that's had this much good will i
mean i played a [ __ ] ton of guild wars 2
and neverwinter um and i really loved
both of those i i still really like
guild wars 2 but even those communities
had you know the
angry fans where i feel like final
fantasy somehow doesn't like everyone's
just happy about it it doesn't it's got
a very it's such a it's a fascinating
game because of how personal the
connection is with the people who make
it but there's a there's a sort of this
this core group of developers who are
you know on a first name basis with the
community and they're very wholesome and
they really rescued this game where it
was like so bad that it has to had to be
blown up like you they literally had the
moon smash into the planet
like to reset the game it was so bad and
then these other these other people took
over and they just built it with just
like you know blood sweat and tears
they've always treated their community
really well they speak to them very
regularly it's just very wholesome you
know and it's a very rare kind of
connection that you don't find in many
other games particularly these live
service games where people have this
endless thirst for content
but you know one of the best things this
team has done is kind of set people's
expectations appropriately like hey
there's not always going to be more
content go and play some other games
chill out you know what i mean and i
think the community as a result is very
mature about what they ask for and what
they expect and it creates just a really
good relationship so i was reading
something about the real estate market
oh man don't even oh you can buy a house
yeah yeah yeah
it was a lamborghini so interesting it
was like eve online levels of
interesting like a game i've not played
but then i'm gonna read all this this
drama like if you read the eve online
yes
oh my god
archives is the name it's so cool
i'm never going to touch this [ __ ] but
holy [ __ ] don't stop
i want to make if i was a writer i would
write a tv show based on eve's stories
do you want to mean like that is a cool
tv show that i would watch because that
[ __ ] is wild you know what i mean yeah
but i mean the final fantasy stuff does
seem
[Music]
like the real estate stuff seems vaguely
similar from what i read i don't
remember it very well can either of you
explain it to me or all it is is
basically there's a finite number
there's an actual yeah
and because everything else in the game
is available to everyone but the housing
is finite and uh you know it's bid based
prices so you have these people with
hundreds of millions of gil and they
stand there outside these placards
that's how you buy a house in final
fantasy you can't just buy it you
actually need to stand outside this
placard waiting for it to populate and
it's a random time so you'll have people
standing there clicking for 15 hours
like that's just what you do when you're
like a real real estate market it is
exactly like the like blind house in san
fran is the meme you know what i mean
like that kind of thing
um
but you know eventually they're going to
add some other stuff like they're going
to have farming coming in the next
expansion which people are assuming will
be instanced but don't buy final fantasy
because if you're interested interested
in housing is it's probably not going to
happen for you okay just just buy it for
a cool cool story that will like consume
your 300 hours plus there is a free play
period um
where oh yeah yeah
oh yeah a free trial i'm on the free
trial where you get you can get up to
level six the up to heaven's word i
believe which is the first expansion and
then after that including including
heaven sweat that's yeah concluding with
no restrictions on play time might i add
so yeah which is pretty a pretty good
way to at least you know see if it's for
you i'm really glad i managed to wrangle
this podcast into a final fantasy 14
promotion platform i'm really just like
it's final fantasy and it's out of wow
here we are
sorry
i can't no i just had okay one question
about this so as someone who loves final
fantasy straight up uh where where is
like the dna there is there like what's
the identity like you know yeah like
you're casting like you've got a white
mage and you know there's like all the
armor is ripped from the previous games
you'll have you'll have entire raids
that are actually pulled from like final
fantasy 12 uh and final fantasy 8 was
the most recent one like you you heard
like final fantasy viii soundtrack
remixed in final fantasy 14 force your
way the new version holy [ __ ] man there
is there is no hype more hyper song
across all the video games right now
than force your way final fantasy 14. so
like all that stuff there was even a
near raid by the way which as a massive
fan
the near raid was extraordinary what oh
yeah dude no no no like imagine you know
2b and 9s and they're there and you're
going through the copied factory and
like you have the the sound of like
kichi akabe's soundtrack playing and
remixes of it and it's just like [ __ ]
insane man so good you don't understand
you just have to do it okay no this is
bad
i can't do this to myself
i feel like someone is trying to sell me
heroin and i'm like i know that don't
let it take me i can't do it
yeah then i got some friends who played
this game and they showed me that knee
raid and it was incredible um is that
still a thing yeah yeah yeah it's the
current it's the current endgame raid
like casual raid for final fantasy and
then the hardcore raids are based on
final fantasy viii
so uh and they're pulled from that and
there's all sorts of like you know
easter eggs throughout there if you're a
final fantasy fan it really rewards that
but at the same time you don't have to
have been a hardcore final fantasy fan
you can just jump in and like whatever
off you go so
oh no so yeah rip all your free time
ladies and gentlemen there it goes all
right a lot of what platform where are
we
[Laughter]
well i guess that's a good place to
leave it somehow i don't know how we
ended up here but i'm all right with it
um lots of goodwill there i did want to
say that another game that i feel like
has a very positive community and a
similar way is sea of thieves
yeah updates that i give
i played it after like a year after it
came out or something and
yeah it's
it's they've really kind of brought it
back and it's a lot of fun when you play
co-op i think solo is so much fun not
it's whatever but yeah when you're
playing co-op and you're like giving out
orders okay no you take on this task you
do that and you're managing the shipping
when you're fighting against other
players like that can be really fun and
intense or fighting against a kraken
that pops out of nowhere in the middle
of the sea it is terrifying too yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can just lose
everything like all this uh everything
you've plundered like you want to take
back to base to upgrade your ship but
you could lose all that if you get
wrecked or enemy players could steal
that from you and stuff like it
yeah no it's fun actually yeah it is a
great game and yeah i think they they do
a lot of really good updates and a lot
of um a lot of twitch integrations as
well like i feel like they just support
that community really well um
so my final question and you're you have
short answers only okay you have to be
short no out a while to find fantasy
um i've already said that i think my
current game of the year is death's door
can i get the answer from each of you
for some reason the end of august feels
like the middle of the year for video
games with the way that it's weighted
november so jake what's your current
pick for gaming my brain is broken can i
not go first
i can't remember
oh my god ralph
um okay i very quickly i heard what you
said um i think take two in terms of
like i think take two uh it takes two in
terms of like as a game that was
designed by people you're like whoa holy
[ __ ] man this is insane like the level
designer that is unbelievable and it's
just it's nuts so i think that but the
other the one that i actually think i've
enjoyed the most i played this year was
actually valheim which i dumped a good
70 hours into with some friends and that
game i think is incredible and it really
nails that kind of sense of discovery
that i spoke about earlier it just it
really took me back to the old world of
warcraft days funnily enough like
vanilla wow when you know what's over
that horizon and you're going there with
your friends and i don't know i really
loved it and i and i again it doesn't
have that kind of technical polish that
other games do it's still early access
but i really think it's amazing and when
it comes down to 1.0 like i just think
it's going to blow everyone away that's
my that's my game for 14 hours straight
the first time that i played it you did
right what do you think disgusting oh
okay i got very sweaty
it's not
no i loved it yeah it's it's super fun
yeah definitely
unexpected too it came out of nowhere
mm-hmm very cool yeah um young how about
you
so far man uh it's gotta be between
ratchet and clank uh and uh it takes two
and i think it takes two
takes it for me um because it's just i
mean the the creativity of that co-op
gameplay and the
imagination of uh the
stuff unfolding before you and the
they've implemented so many like
little mini
gameplay elements that only appear for
like one sequence but it's like there's
like the fighting sequence that that
pops out of nowhere like little things
like that and yeah the designers had
their work cut out for them yeah making
so many mechanics that are used one time
there's one level that's basically a
diablo like action
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's freaking insane
like
and it all worked
well enough
um and you've got like just really
memorable moments like i'll all i'll say
is the elephant
oh my god
i was like what is going on when i when
i eventually do a video on that game it
will be about that scene because that
scene is just
too much man it's so much that plus the
ending of 12 minutes they're the they're
the big wtf moments of uh
12 minutes is almost every minute of 12
minutes though i don't even know if it
was just the ending which i also enjoyed
i really like that game i i enjoyed
because i've really enjoyed talking to
people about it sure and i i like you
said earlier young with uh metal gear
it's like any game where you walk away
and you want to talk to everyone about
it i feel like it gets points for that
like i'm like i just want to chat to
everybody and get everybody's
impressions of this and even with 12
minutes i made people who i knew would
hate that game play it i was like
yeah mike will play it and i was like
you're gonna hate it and i really want
you to play it and he did and i was like
great let's chat about it this is gonna
be awesome so it's i feel like it's
really fun in that regard and um similar
to it takes two being super creative i
felt similarly with psychonauts too that
i was like holy [ __ ] you just you keep
changing the the video game every two
minutes and i'm like oh just i'll just
keep taking it like it's it's wonderful
though i do feel like it takes to as
much more unique experience than that
joseph harris he's doing a great job
he is the oscars indeed [ __ ]
it
all right jacob you decided uh you guys
mentioned a lot of them psychonauts 2 is
up there
it takes 2 is up there for me other than
that it's hitman 3 for obvious reasons
and chivalry too i keep playing
i have no real uh like professional
critical opinion about it it's literally
just like gamer brain
going back to it playing and having such
good
adrenaline rush instant satisfaction fun
like every night i just hop in like if
i'm downloading something else and i'm
waiting i'll fire up chivalry too and
cut like a couple of dudes heads off and
a multi-player around and just get that
fantasy from now on buddy
yeah i haven't played chivalry too but
uh i did also want to mention it just
because we haven't spoken about it um i
really enjoyed returnal i thought it was
it was a really good time and i'm kind
of sad that the conversation seemed to
disappear so fast and i don't know if
maybe that's because people found it a
little bit too difficult to persist
um
that it people moved on from it really
quickly which i found to be a bummer
because it's pretty awesome it was
pretty finite though like you were
you're really looking at sort of 10 to
20 hours of play depending on like how
easily you could crack it
and
yeah i think that come game of the year
conversation though that'll it'll
definitely pop back up again because
certainly like it's design it's combat
yeah um it's it's it's roguelike
structure was a little shaky but i just
think it nailed so many things so i
definitely said the dual sense yeah like
i loved what they did with the
controller absolutely yeah so i i
definitely expect it'll be on those
lists discussed i don't think it'll
necessarily take this top spot but i
think it's definitely one of those games
that you'll that you'll hear more about
so yeah yeah
um it's been a good year so far
surprisingly because usually like right
after consoles come out we don't get
[ __ ]
um it's usually really slow and i guess
it has been in terms of like massive
blockbuster titles but it's still been
really good i've had a great time
playing video games oh yeah so yeah i'll
take it totally
what i'm getting for uh upcoming games
kina why why did i mention this yeah
game ranks videos and for three months
in a row we did like you know top 10
games releasing in this month this month
this month and every time we had it on
there the next day they announced like
yeah we're bumping it up yeah we're
moving it and it's like come on you like
another reason to create another top ten
man let's go add review let's keep doing
it do it time to range
i imagine
that game's gonna cause oh they just had
a preload and file size leak how did
that happen i wonder
um interesting it's gonna take a long
time to animate that game but it's from
an animation studio it looks like
whimsical ghibli-esque like it's
beautiful yeah i'm i'm definitely down
to play it one i mean what a weird weird
link to have sorry jake
it's i was just gonna say isn't it crazy
that resident evil village came out two
years ago
i really did shut up
we're not even talking about it
totally resident evil village wow that
is totally forgot about that wow it's
also i keep struggling with the thought
that we are closer to 2022 than we are
to 2020. it's a hard that's hard
it's a lot to take in
i don't know what time it's anymore i
try not to think about it
it's all it's all about and yeah perhaps
in the chat it is not whatever the
opposite of pog is
please
twitch i don't know
um all right this is super fun thank you
guys for joining me yeah i'd love to do
it again sometime and i'm expecting you
all about that i feel like it's a good
group of people to chat about video
games if you have a town but for anyone
who doesn't know you jake where can
people find you on the internet uh
twitter and instagram jake baldino
youtube.com jake baldino is where i just
talk about whatever i like and just tank
the algorithm as much as possible and
then my day job is game ranks uh i do
the friday show every week i've never
missed a week in like seven years
wow
and before you buy videos so that's me
ralph how about you uh i'm skill up i'm
on youtube and that's it really on
twitter as well unfortunately god i wish
i wasn't um
and yeah just doing the whole review
thing and weekly news so check it out
skill up on youtube
young how about you i'm on uh my channel
uh youtube.com slash young yeah i'm on
twitter at yangya and if you want to
hire me for voiceover stuff uh
yangyavio.com
if i was making a game i would hire you
as a voiceover for sure young no doubt
if i had that kind of power okay i'd
talk to you about it
sadly they'd be like [ __ ] off
as the god of war
yes
yes yes would you like to play kratos
i could definitely make that happen that
works
[Laughter]
for everyone watching
everyone watching on twitch i will put
this up on youtube tomorrow probably
okay i think i don't know what i'm going
to call this video but you know we'll
figure it out and yeah hopefully we'll
get this group back together again to
have a nice chat sometime
thank you everybody for watching thank
you
thank you bye-bye